one of the fastest growing companies in
our portfolio is a company that uses
robotics
to grow worms
in vertical farms
as of 2022 they will be the world's
largest producer of worms
and so you say why would i care about
that one of the problems in the world is
protein sustainability
and so what worms are able to do is
become a protein source for fish
so in the wild about 15
of all input that a fish takes is
insects
but now more than 50 of fish are grown
in fish farms and they were getting zero
insects
and so we were depleting the world's
supply of things like anchovies to feed
fish
so they started feeding fish
carbohydrates so wheat products and it
turns out that fish mortality goes up
because they don't all digest wheat and
so they started giving hormones and
amino acids and antibiotics to then
prevent inflammation from hormones and
we were creating an industrial system
similar to what we did with you know
cows and chickens in this country
and so this entrepreneur said
i think i can solve that problem if i
can grow insects at scale
and so he tried 100 different types of
insects it turns out some that sound
like a good idea like grasshoppers uh
crickets and the like you can't grow in
really close quarters because they
become cannibalistic when you do so we
had to cycle through a bunch of insect
types he settled on this type of worm
it's called a mealworm
and they could mass produce the larva
but what they do is think of stack trays
that go really high
and robotic arms that lift the stack
drop in feed drop the stack pick the
next thing up in the stack and drop the
feed and they go up and down then
periodically they pull out a tray flip
it over a sieve get all the manure out
and put the worms back
the manure makes about 60
of our total volume of what we create
and we sell it as an organic fertilizer
at maturation the worms are crushed you
take the liquid by-product and it
becomes an input into pet food to make
dry kibbles water soluble
and there already are products that do
that they typically come from poultry
but we're a perfect substitute for that
the most value is the dry cake powder
and that then becomes an input for fish
food
and it turns out we did a three and a
half year study
to prove that we could reduce fish
mortality
and not impact the taste of fish
suddenly we have so much demand we can't
even produce enough worms as i said
we're building the world's largest
factory to produce worms now
and we went from zero
to a hundred million dollars in bookings
in one year fantastic
that's extraordinary just think about
all the problems we have
you think about how lucky we are to be
capital allocators and to work with
these amazing founders i am so positive
and i i know you are too
about we can solve every problem if we
have amazing entrepreneurs
who are properly incentivized um and are
given the capital and if we have the
will as a society to actually deploy
these exciting things and it really is
about willpower we can correct i believe
and i'm curious to your answer i believe
we can cure
and reverse in fact global warming you
would say it's a complicated topic i
can't recommend highly enough to every
reader if you care about sustainability
of the planet to read a book called
collapse
and it's written by one of my favorite
authors in the world jared diamond
and jared diamond won the pulitzer prize
for his amazing book called guns germs
and steel
so collapse studies societies around the
world that collapse
and why do they collapse and like gun
turns in steel he says here's the
proximate causes so the proximate causes
of why the west conquered the rest were
guns germs and steel but he says but
someone needs to ask why did the west
get gun terms and steel so that's the
whole premise of that book the premise
of collapse is we know the proximate
cause of why society's collapse is war
yep or
famine yep or some sort of catastrophic
event like water being reduced
but then he says what causes that and he
goes back upstream to say what causes
why like he looked for example at rwanda
and why was there genocide in rwanda
and it came down to agriculture because
they were subdividing the land so much
and every subdivision went from father
to son and it usually went to firstborn
son
and they would subdivide and subdivide
and subdivide the land as population
grew to a point where they could no
longer hand out
land to their offspring
and they had a limitation on the number
of acres of farmable land and it started
leading to civil conflict so he goes
back up to looking at things like
agriculture
and he's and one uh thing he studied was
um easter island the moa and why did
easter island collapse so easter island
went from this really religious place
that had gods and norms and rules
and then they over time they became
cannibals and killed each other and ate
each other and see what led to that and
what they did is they studied the diets
of the middens so that they studied the
middens to determine the diets of what
people ate
and what they figured out was
the first thing they do is they cut down
all the trees
and once they cut down all the trees
they no longer had fish in their diet
because they no longer could build boats
to have fish oh my god and so their
calories were reduced and therefore
their output was reduced and therefore
they led to civil conflict and their
entire religion was wiped out and they
became cannibalistic and so anyway this
book it's a wonderful book and he
basically says that they're oh you did
okay so a theory called malthusian
theory which is the more you produce in
agriculture and output uh the more
population will grow to filth that's the
malthusian
theory it can induce traffic you build
more roads people travel more exactly
but what he said is you need a
combination of technology
but you need societal change you need
people wanting to consume less
and i think that's the other area and
that's what gives me great hope about
gen z and people coming behind gen z is
they're growing up with a culture of
wanting to drive electric cars
wanting to consume less wanting to have
lower carbon footprint wanting to find
ways to not have to import their
products from around the world that has
carbon emissions and wanting less and i
think that's got to be the world we live
in in the future
listen as a foundry sometimes finishing
a project is way way harder than
starting it starting is easy finishing
is hard shiny new ideas are great you
have them all the time and sometimes you
and your team don't have enough
bandwidth to finish the mission and
that's where fiverr comes in they fix
the issue by creating fiverr business
f-i-v-e-r
fiverr business will get you access to
an all-star team of freelancers plus all
the tools and support you need to easily
integrate them into your existing
workflow there's no more guessing
there's no more interviews fiverr's team
of dedicated business success managers
will help match you with the best talent
for your team in other words they got a
manager of the talent over there doing
what i was doing how brilliant is that
and you will be able to save and share
your favorite freelancers for future
projects all in one simple dashboard we
love it here we've hired a bunch of
researchers to find local people to
invite to our event boom fibre got it
done for us they deliver us the goods
the event was a success stop wasting
time searching for talent and just leave
it to fiverr business they do a great
job right now you can sign up for free
that's right free for the first year and
you save ten percent on your purchases
of fiber business with the promo code
jason that's right the promo code is
jason just go to fiverr.com business and
use the promo code jason to get 10 off f
i v e r r.com
business